there's two things I think that are
required for I mean this is how I've
lived my life for great engineering you
surround yourself in your personal life
by people you trust
and then in your professional life from
the engineering perspective with the
team
with an incredible team
and everything else doesn't matter that
allows you not to focus on other groups
how they're [ __ ] you over how they're
like trying to manipulate a collude and
all that kind of stuff you focus on
Solutions and you find a way around all
the difficult [ __ ]
that's it if you have people in your
life you can trust
that's like lifelong you said like some
people you're with for the summer
for a year find people you can be with
for your whole life do you have people
in your life that you trust like really
trust
no I trust God
at any point a human being can like I
could like if I like go and like
really
you know treat this guy like a piece of
[ __ ] or do this am I supposed to you
know trust him to be loyal and stay in
the situation or I trust people to be
people and people are flawed and people
can have the right intentions but only
makes sense for us to work together when
our agendas align
when Kim was pulled really far to to the
to the left our agenda is no longer you
know aligned so that made the marriage
impossible it in a line where it's like
oh I could wear a red hat that can help
her to get Alice Johnson out of jail
because Trump's willing to do that for
my wife because I was the only person in
my position that stood up and said wait
a second I like you you know because but
isn't there a deeper agenda the human
agenda of just being in love like that's
just Paul were you talking about red hat
is just politics right I mean the world
is becoming more and more transactional
every day and actually marriages are
actually uh actually originally based on
transactions you know and that's why
they're less needed the more autonomous
as we come or the world makes it less
needed I feel like we do need each other
I feel like we do need someone we can
always
you know count on it's like I'm yay
pulled away by King Koopa which is the
media the politics the promise oh we're
going to keep you safe so the thing the
reason why I get you know really
frustrated with Kris Jenner is she says
losing Rob Kardashian was the greatest
mistake of her life but she never gave
Kim's hand over in marriage because this
is the bottom line
when men came back we were millionaires
or whatever right you're telling me you
just hand her hand over a marriage that
your daughter's not successful handing
your hand over in marriage too but no
she had to still be the husband to all
of her daughters and
we see what the results are consistently
so that's where I get you know
frustrated it's like let that go let
this person
do what you made mistakes on don't make
this person relive those same mistakes
and then put that agenda into my
daughters too